aquí tengo estos tres vectores que viven
en r3 que viven en el espacio y lo que
quiero hacer con el conjunto que
contiene estos tres vectores es probar
lo mismo que ya hemos visto en los
vídeos pasados es decir lo que quiero
hacer es aplicar todo lo que hemos
aprendido en los vídeos pasados a este
conjunto de tres vectores y bueno las
preguntas que nos hacíamos más
usualmente cuando tenemos un conjunto de
tres vectores o de n vectores en rn era
saber si estos vectores en primer lugar
que espacio vectorial generaban eso era
muy importante saber si el espacio
vectorial era r 3 en este caso fíjate
que como tenemos tres componentes el
espacio generado si fueran linealmente
independientes sería entre 3 pero bueno
esto lo que nos queremos preguntar y
además nos preguntábamos si estos
vectores eran linealmente independientes
o linealmente dependientes linealmente
independientes o dependientes
bueno pues y bueno yo sé que me vas a
decir que la segunda pregunta responde
sin problema la primera pregunta sin
embargo siempre que pensemos en
dependencia o independencia lineal es
muy bueno hacernos estas 2
ya sea por separado o juntas y tratar de
resolverlas bueno vamos a ver qué onda
con estos vectores y son linealmente
independientes o linealmente
dependientes entonces no voy a tomar una
combinación lineal de esos vectores y va
a ser esta hace uno que multiplica el
primer vector más c 2 que va a
multiplicar el segundo vector el segundo
vector es del 2 13 + c 3 que va a
multiplicar al tercer vector que es el
menos 1 0 2 y bueno yo voy a ver si esta
combinación lineal que yo tengo aquí me
da cualquier vector recuerda que en el
vídeo pasado vimos que si nosotros
igualdad vamos al vector 0 nos dábamos
cuenta si era linealmente dependiente o
linealmente independiente sin embargo en
esta ocasión me voy a querer tomar
cualquier vector para ver si dado
cualquier vector en r3 fíjate tienen
tres componentes dado cualquier vector
en r3 lo puedo escribir con una
combinación lineal de todos los demás es
exactamente lo mismo que lo que vimos en
el vídeo pasado sin embargo en esta
ocasión yo lo que quiero es tomarme a un
vector a un vector cualquiera en r3 y
ver si lo puedo generar lo voy a ver con
un poco más general así que bueno lo que
aprendidos que si tenemos una constante
afuera de un vector la constante
multiplica a cada una de las entradas de
este vector por lo tanto vamos a poner
esta constante que adentro c1 c1 c1 y
después tengo otra constante que
multiplica traductor entonces voy a
meterse 2 multiplicando a cada una de
las entradas del segundo vector y de
manera análoga para hacer 3
voy a poner ese 3 a esta constante
multiplicando a cada una de las entradas
del vector 3 y bueno ya esto se ve mucho
más tranquilo porque ya podemos
encontrar aquí nuestro sistema de
ecuaciones tenemos tres incógnitas tres
ecuaciones y entonces vamos a escribir
las dados los tres vectores primero me
voy a fijar en la primer componente o en
la componente xy me queda que ese 11 por
ser 1 s 1 más dos veces 2 - 1 por 7 3
que ese 3 esto es igual
aa esto es la en primer lugar esta sería
mi primera actuación con un componente x
ahora vamos a fijarnos en mi segunda
componente en mi componente y vamos a
hacer su respectiva igualdad
me quedaría que menos 1 y a esto le
agrego c2 y después me queda más 0 c 3
pero 0 por lo que sea es 0 entonces esto
se cancela es igual a b ya tengo un
segunda ecuación que sale de la segunda
componente y ahora me voy a fijar en mi
tercer componente y que da dos veces uno
más tres veces 2
y esto tengo que agregar dos veces tres
más dos veces de tres esto tiene que ser
igual a c y si te das cuenta aquí ya
tengo tres ecuaciones y tres incógnitas
y yo lo que quiero saber es el valor
para hacer uno para este 2 y para hace 3
por lo tanto lo único que tengo que
resolver es este sistema de ecuaciones
si te das cuenta en la ecuación número
dos nos parece ese 3 pero a mí es lo que
se me ocurre es tomar la ecuación número
uno y la cuestión número dos e intentar
cancelar se uno porque segundo se
cancela luego luego aquí tengo a menos c
1 arriba tengo hace uno y después puede
operar con la ecuación 2 y con la
ecuación 3 y también cancelar hace 1 al
final lo que quiero que veas es que voy
a utilizar el método de eliminación o de
suma y resta para yo poder obtener los
valores de c1 c2 y c3 así que bueno
juntemos la ecuación número 1 y la
ecuación número 2
de estas dos que me va a quedar si hago
suma directa de estas dos me queda que
ese 1 menos uno se cancelan y no me
queda nada después me queda 12 2 más 2
me quedan tres veces c 2 y después tengo
menos de 3 +0 pues es menos de 3 aquí no
hay ningún problema
entonces me queda menos 3 y después me
queda a más bien esto es igual aa más
veo además a este sumando estas dos
ecuaciones entonces me queda de massa y
bueno ya tengo una ecuación que
solamente tiene hace dos y hace tres por
lo tanto tengo que encontrar otra
ecuación que solamente tenga c2 y c3 y
voy a poner acá arriba la primera
actuación para que no nos vayamos
perdiendo con ella me quedase 12 veces
c2 c3 igual a esta ecuación la primera
me va a servir para despejar al final
ese 1 y bueno ahora voy a ocupar la
tercera ecuación y la primera ecuación y
voy a cancelar también hace 1 para que
me quede mi segunda ecuación que tenga
que ver solamente con c2 y c3 por lo
tanto voy a multiplicar por menos 2 de
ecuación de arriba y me va a quedar
menos 2 que va a multiplicar hace 1 me
queda
- 12 1 esto es con la idea otra vez de
cancelar hacer uno y después me quedan
menos cuatro ceros aquí usted vuelve
positivo porque es menos por menos me da
más más dos veces de tres y recuerda que
hay que multiplicar toda la ecuación
también hay que multiplicar el lado
derecho y me quedaría menos dos veces y
bueno ahora lo que voy a hacer para
cancelar hace uno es sumarle cuestión
número uno esta ecuación modificada con
la ecuación número tres y entonces que
voy a obtener me quedan menos 12 112 1
esto se cancelan por lo tanto no se pone
nada
después me queda tres veces dos menos
cuatro ceros es lo mismo que menos de
dos o menos cuatro ceros más 13 2 es lo
mismo que menos de 2 y después nos queda
dos veces de tres más dos veces de tres
esto es lo mismo que cuatro veces c3
entonces menos de dos más cuatro veces
tres esto es igual a c menos dos a menos
dos más de entonces esto es igual hace
menos dos a menos 2
y si te das cuenta ya tengo otra
ecuación la cual tiene que ver solamente
con c2 y c3 ya elimine mi primer
incógnita
un sistema de dos por dos así que
déjenme poner la pantalla un poco más
hacia la derecha para que se vea bien lo
que voy a hacer me queda que la primera
ecuación de la c-12 bc2 bc3 igual am
esta ecuación me va a servir al final
después me va a quedar que tres veces de
2 menos de 3 es igual
además am es la segunda ecuación tres
veces de 2 - c 3 es igual a b masa y ya
no tengo espacio entonces déjenme poner
la pantalla más hacia la derecha para
que quede mucho espacio muy bien y ahora
de estas dos ecuaciones voy a cancelar
hace 2 si te das cuenta aquí tengo hace
2 negativo por lo tanto si yo multiplico
esta segunda ecuación por 3 solamente
por 3 se va a cancelar se 2 cuando yo la
sume con la primera y que me va a quedar
bueno voy a multiplicar por tres la
segunda ecuación y que voy a obtener me
queda 3 por menos de 2 esto es lo mismo
que menos 3 bs 2 con tres veces 2 se va
a cancelar entonces vamos bien ok
déjenme poner aquí el 3
entonces escribo me parece bien que les
vaya cancelando una por una y vamos a
ver qué es lo que me resulta después no
queda 3
4 12 12 1 es lo mismo que 11 3 entonces
esto es 11 s 3 vamos a ver si lo hice
bien 4 por 3 son 12 12 menos uno es 11 s
3 perfecto y después me va a quedar 3
porsche menos 2 a también por escribirlo
siempre este se cancela aquí me queda 12
ese 3 - 1 es 11 s 311 s 3 y después
tengo a 3 x c menos 2
es lo mismo que 13 menos 6 y lo voy a
escribir todo el recorrido y ahorita lo
simplificamos me queda 13 menos 6 am y
arriba tengo de más a entonces más b más
y después vamos a operar con lajas es
menos 6 y ya esto hay que sumarle b
massa es decir la ecuación de arriba
pero antes de simplificar las haz lo que
quiero que te des cuenta es que voy tras
el valor de ese 3 si yo tengo el valor
de ese 3 por lo tanto no puede sustituir
en la segunda ecuación y entonces voy a
obtener el valor de ese 2 y ya con el
valor de ese 2 y de c3 voy a poder
sustituir en la ecuación número 1
así obtener el valor de ese 1 también
atrás eso es lo que voy y bueno aquí se
pueden reducir las hadas como te había
dicho menos 6 más me queda menos 5 am y
ya obtengo que 11 bcs 3 es lo mismo que
13 menos 5 a ver entonces déjame darte
el valor de este 3 ya despejada c 3 es
igual a un onceavo voy a pasar
dividiendo el 11 entonces me queda un
onceavo que multiplica a 3 cm menos 5 am
y ya tenemos hace 3 ya tenemos un paso
de aquí porque ya obtenemos el valor de
ese 3 si nosotros lo que queremos es
también saberse 2 pues lo único que hay
que hacer es despejar hace 2 de esta
ecuación porque ya tenemos el valor de
ese 3 y de hecho nos quedaría que tres
veces de 2 es igual a b más a más de 3
el valor de ese 3 que acabo de encontrar
o dicho de otra manera si lo que quiero
saber es el valor de ese 2 completamente
despejado entonces me va a quedar que
ese 2 es igual a un tercio estoy pasando
dividiendo el 3 que multiplica a b más
c3 ok ya tengo el valor de ese 2 ya
tengo el valor de es de 3 por lo tanto
ya puedo saber el valor de ese 1
dada la primera ecuación por eso las
escribía yo aquí arriba si yo paso del
otro lado hace 3 12 2 entonces voy a
obtener el valor de c1 c1 es igual a am
ya esto le voy a quitar menos 2 veces 2
y después voy a agregarle ese 3 lo único
que hice fue despejar hacia uno de la
primera ecuación y ya por fin obtuve el
valor de ese 3 c 2 y c 1 y entonces
estoy diciendo que para cualquier a b y
c dado cualquier vector que tenga tres
componentes que sean a b y c
yo voy a obtener el valor de ese 3 c 2 y
c 1 y recuerda que lo más importante
aquí es no equivocarnos y creo que me
equivoqué yo siento que hay algo raro
aquí oh claro ya vi dónde está en error
si te das cuenta c 3 es igual a 1 si
hago de tres veces menos 5 a ya esto hay
que agregarle b aquí estaba la b que me
falta te das cuenta entonces a esta vez
no la puse en esta de aquí entonces
adentro del paréntesis
de c3 le tengo que agregar esta vez ya
sabía yo que por aquí algo me haría mal
aquí está más verde y entonces ya tengo
por fin ahora si bien el valor de ese 3
y bueno ya que estamos en esto de
genéticas y las otras dos constantes
también se 2 es igual a un tercio debe
más a más de tres lo único que hice fue
despejar este 2 aquí está hace tres que
ya la corregir hice unos y ya tengo este
entonces déjeme ver c 2 estaba bien un
tercio debe más a más de 3 esto en la
ecuación de acá arriba y entonces ese 2
también está bien y cc 2 también está
bien entonces se 1 es igual a am menos
dos veces dos más c 3 esto por la
ecuación número uno por lo tanto también
está bien muy bien y ya tengo a mis tres
constantes escritas en términos de a b y
c esto que quiere decir que dado
cualquier vector en r3 cualquier vector
que tenga como componentes a b y c yo te
voy a poder dar una c 1-1
2 y 1 c 3 tales que al hacer una
combinación lineal con mis vectores
pueda obtener este vector lo que quiere
decir que el espacio generado por estos
tres vectores por este conjunto es r 3 y
ya tengo la respuesta a mi primer
pregunta ahora estos vectores son
linealmente independientes y esta es la
pregunta que quiero responder a
continuación ya sé que el espacio
vectorial generado por estos tres
vectores es r 3 pero ahora para probar
si son linealmente independientes o
dependientes lo que voy a hacer es tomar
una combinación lineal de estos tres
vectores otra vez con c1 c2 c3 pero
utilizando la información que vi en el
vídeo pasado voy a igualarlo al vector 0
la idea es que igualando esta
combinación lineal al vector 0 me voy a
dar cuenta si los vectores son
linealmente independientes o linealmente
dependientes recuerdan en el vídeo
pasado vimos que esto pasaba si solo si
era el vector 0 y además pedíamos una
restricción muy importante la
restricción que pedíamos era la
siguiente nos íbamos a fijar en las
constantes y si la única forma de
obtener esta combinación lineal es que
las constantes sean todas
pero es decir c1 y c2 y c3 al mismo
tiempo sean iguales y sean igual a cero
entonces quería decir que mi conjunto
tenía vectores linealmente
independientes se acuerdan y por lo
tanto obtenía tres dimensiones esto es
si eran linealmente independientes así
que dejan escribirlo para que no se nos
olvide atrás lo que vamos dice uno y c2
y c3 son iguales es decir se uno igual
hace dos igual hace tres y además son
iguales a cero entonces esto implicaba
que el vector eran linealmente
independientes este es un sí solo si el
vector fuera dependiente lo que nos
íbamos a encontrar es que al menos una
de estas constantes ya sea c1 c2 c3
tenía que ser distinta de cero con una
me bastaba para decir que el sistema era
linealmente dependiente pero bueno este
vector cero es lo mismo que tener tres
componentes la componente a b y c y
nosotros generamos unas igualdades de c1
c2 y c3 que dependen de a dvi de c por
lo tanto vamos a sustituir el valor de
abc que en este caso es 0
una de mis ecuaciones que yo tengo aquí
tengo que ese 3 es igual a un onceavo
que multiplica a 3 por 0 menos 500 pues
estos 000 y al final un onceavo por 0 me
da que ese 3 también es cero entonces
este 3 también es cero
0 - 0 0 por un onceavo es cero
ahora vamos a aplicarnos el c 2 c 13 00
b es cero y un tercio por cero me va a
dar también que ese 12 0 y vamos a
fijarnos en c 1 c 3 0 c 2 también es 0 a
también es 0
entonces me queda que ese 1 pues es
igual a 0 también y te das cuenta estoy
obteniendo que mis tres constantes tanto
c1 c2 c3 son igual a 0 cuando se cumple
esta combinación lineal
la única solución de esta combinación
lineal es que mis tres constantes sean
cero cuando yo quiero que el primer
vector por ser uno más el segundo vector
por de dos más el tercer vector por ese
3 sea igual al vector cero tiene que
cumplir que forzosamente c1 c2 y c3 sean
las 30 lo que implica que el sistema o
que este conjunto tiene
los vectores linealmente independientes
recuerdan en el vídeo pasado habíamos
visto que si pasaba que las tres
constantes sean igual a cero entonces mi
conjunto tenía vectores linealmente
independientes o recuerdan otra forma de
verlo es que ninguno de estos tres
vectores se puede ver como una
combinación lineal de los otros dos y
entonces tengo tres vectores que su
espacio vectorial generado seré 3 y que
son linealmente independientes y bueno
tal vez esta información sea un poco más
obvia porque al final lo que te quería
contener los siguientes si tenemos tres
vectores y son linealmente
independientes pues es muy claro que van
a generar a todo r3 o dicho otra manera
tenemos tres vectores y su espacio
generado es r 3 entonces tienen que ser
linealmente independientes porque al
final cada uno de ellos está agregando
una nueva dirección pues imagínate que
uno de ellos supongamos el tercero no
fuera linealmente independiente de los
otros dos es decir se puede ver como una
combinación lineal de los otros dos esto
quiere decir que entonces vive en el
espacio vectorial generado por los otros
dos vectores que al final si tenemos dos
vectores que son en linealmente
independientes entonces su espacio
el generador es un plano te acuerdas que
eso lo vimos en los vídeos pasados por
lo tanto este tercer vector tendría que
existir en ese plano y por lo tanto no
podrían generar como espacio vectorial a
r3 recuerda que si tenemos tres vectores
que son linealmente independientes cada
uno de ellos da una nueva dirección tal
vez no sean forzosamente ortogonales
pero puede ser que un vector se vea si
el otro se ve así y el otro se vea por
acá y entonces generen tarde o temprano
todo r3 nos vemos en el siguiente vídeo